if the women are happy to share you
because you're just so amazing they want
to have kids with you no matter the fact
that you have kids with other women then
so be it I don't care it's probably not
something that I could do as long as
he's taking care of all of them not just
financially but emotionally and
physically and all of that and that's
good but I think it can be very
difficult to do I think one woman's
difficult enough right we're so
demanding my brother always says to me
that women are very draining and it's
true we want your time your money your
love your affection everything we want
everything from you you know and then
how are you going to give that to
multiple women I think that's difficult